este vehículo traslada a julian assange
de nuevo a prisión
la jueza vanessa master negó el pedido
de libertad bajo fianza para el fundador
de wikileaks al considerar que tiene un
incentivo para fugarse y que todavía no
ha ganado su caso una decisión rechazada
por los allegados del periodista
esto es una gran decepción
julian no debería estar en la prisión de
belmarsh en primer lugar instó al
departamento de justicia a retirar los
cargos y al presidente de eeuu a
perdonar a lluvias
creemos que es injusto e ilógico como
tal cuando se considera su decisión de
hace dos días sobre la salud de julian
sudeste covap out tour jones house es un
joven es inhumano e ilógico e lógico el
mismo tribunal rechazó hace dos días la
extradición de assange a eeuu alegando
que las condiciones de encarcelamiento
en ese país afectarían su débil salud
mental y podrían empujarlo al suicidio
ese antecedente esperanzó a los
seguidores de assange sobre su posible
liberación una esperanza que se tradujo
en desilusión
es absolutamente repugnante porque es un
hombre enfermo y debería ser puesto en
libertad bajo fianza sólo quieren que
mueran
varios manifestantes fueron arrestados
son después de la audiencia por no
dispersarse violando las restricciones
contra el kobe 19
ahora a sánchez deberá esperar en la
cárcel de alta seguridad de belmarsh que
se resuelva el recurso de eeuu para su
extradición en ese país afronta 17
cargos por espionaje y 1 por intrusión
informática por lo que podría recibir
una pena máxima de 175 años de prisión